they they have left interest rates on
hold at 0.1 percent that's not really
a surprise quantitative easing the the
process whereby they're
they're buying up government bonds
creating money buying of government
bonds essentially kind of
stimulating the economy that's unchanged
as well they're still kind of
stimulating still buying those bonds but
not doing any more
than they were doing previously but the
main focus has been on two other things
what they say about negative interest
rates now i know
the idea of negative interest rates
sounds kind of crazy a bank potentially
paying you
uh for you having uh for you borrowing
money from it i mean i
struggle to get around my head around it
myself um but it's a reality in other
parts of the world
and thus far the bank has been trying to
work out whether it could implement it
in this country if it needed to and what
they've said
today is that they are ordering banks
around the country
to get ready for it within six months
now
they say this shouldn't be taken as a
sign that negative interest rates are in
any way
imminent but they say they want the
financial system to be ready for it just
in case they're needed
within six months so that's the the
story on negative interest rates
as for the state of the economy which i
think is the other big thing a lot of
people are focusing on well
there have been some slight changes to
their forecasts and and let me just kind
of go through i've just received it now
so uh this is uh this is just as i look
at their numbers
um they've slightly upgraded what they
expect
uh to be the final word on gdp growth so
the growth of the economy
for last year ever so slightly upgraded
it downgraded it for this year now
that's not a surprise because
uh of what we're seeing right now the
lockdown uh that's come into place so
previously
uh they were talking about growth of
seven and a quarter percent
uh in this year we're at the moment now
they think it's five percent still very
strong growth but not as strong as it
was
previously and of course not getting
back to where we were before covert 19.
but then in 2022 they are expecting
slightly stronger growth than they
previously expected so essentially
you're talking about weaker growth in
the short term
slightly stronger growth in the the
medium term
um and inflation on the other hand
staying
more or less uh close uh to that two
percent mark so
broadly speaking negative interest rates
certainly a part of it
banks need to get ready for it growth
slightly weaker in the short term
slightly stronger
in the in the longer term and interest
rates and monetary policy on hold